Can you hear me? Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to this session.
My name is Jelani Zarif. I'm from Johns Hopkins University School of Medicine in
the Sidney Kimmel Comprehensive Cancer Center.
Hello, everyone. Thank you for coming. I'm Sonik Preethalik.
I am a translational neuro-oncologist at West Virginia University,
Morgantown.
And we
are excited to share this session.
Our first talk will be from Jackson Weir from Harvard.
He
is a PhD candidate,
and the title of his talk is "Bone Repair External State Program Drives
Cancer Cell Dedifferentiation and Immune Invasion in Melanoma."
Jackson, floor is yours.
Thank you.
Great. Hello, everyone. My name is Jackson.
I'm a PhD candidate in Fay Chen's lab at the Broad, and I'm
excited to talk about some spatial profiling that we've been doing over the last
couple of years in melanoma.
So for really five or 10 years now, we've been doing single-cell RNA
sequencing on lots of tumors, and we've cataloged these
transcriptional programs that are underlying the key cell types
in tumors. And in parallel,
maybe the last five years, spatial methods have enabled us to project
these cell types from the tumors into their native tissue context and understand
which cell types co-localize together.
But really the Holy Grail is to understand the relationship between these two
things, to understand how a cell's environment shapes its
fine-grained cell state.
And the way that we've been thinking about this in our lab is through this idea of
a cell has both an internal state but also an external state.
So in the same way that we define an internal state as a set of genes
that co-vary across cells, we define an external state as a set
of ligands that co-vary in a cell's neighborhood.
And to really understand this link between internal states and cell neighborhoods,
I think we've been technology limited
by some of the spatial technologies that existed.
So a couple of years ago, we developed this method called Slide-Tags, which is a
method for truly single-cell spatial genomics.
It works by we take a tissue section, and we melt it onto a bead array,
where each bead has
spatial barcodes, millions of spatial barcodes attached to the bead via
this photoclavable linker. So we hit the tissue and the beads with UV light,
and we release the spatial barcodes into the tissue.
We then isolate the nuclei and then profile them with single cell, and we can read
out the spatial positions of each cell and get truly single-cell spatial
profiling.
And in our initial paper, we used Slide-Tags to profile this one pilot melanoma
sample. And we have TCR information for the T cells, as
well as state information for all the cells.
And what we find is that there's this one expanded CD8 T cell
clonotype that differentially infiltrates into two
lobes or two clones of the tumor. So we have this one
lobe or clone that is more melanocytic.
It's in this melanocytic-like state, and this is where all the CD8 T cells are
infiltrating. But then there are very few CD8 T cells in this more mesenchymal
region of the tumor.
So we had three questions that we wondered, and we wanted to go about answering
them in a more systematic way. So one, is which niches are supporting
this T cell expansion? Two, which niches are excluding the CD8 T
cells? And then finally, how are these niches interacting, and what's the crosstalk
between niche and tumor?
So working with Nir Hacohen's group and Moshe Sedgfeldman's group at the Broad and
MGH,
we collected this cohort of 30 Slide-Tags samples across
metastatic human metastatic melanoma samples, across different metastatic sites
with varying response to immune checkpoint blockade.
And to start, we're going to forget about the tumor cells for a second and just
focus on the immune and the stromal compartments.
And we wanted to learn what the immune hub structure in melanoma looked like.
So what we did is we took every
pairwise combination of cell types, and we asked whether or not these cell
types are enriched,
spatially enriched or co-localized, or whether they're depleted in each
other's neighborhood using this permutation testing framework.
And I'm not going to talk about all the niches today,
but I'm going to just highlight a couple.
So first we find these stem immunity hubs that exist in melanoma that have been
reported in other tumor types. So these are organized by these CCL19
positive fibroblasts, and this is where most of the stem-like
tumor-reactive CD8 T cells live.
We find that the cycling tumor-reactive CD8s are found around
CXCL10-positive macrophages. And then
the tumor-reactive CD8s that lose their TCF7 expression, so they're no longer in
this stem-like state, exist in what we call these immune effector hubs, which
have lots of NK cells and these SIGLEC-10-positive macrophages that we think are
efferocytosing the
dying tumor cells that the immune effector cells are killing.
But then we have this other hub, this fourth hub, that we call the
anti-inflammatory hub, that has SPP1 macrophages, POSTN
fibroblasts, and we don't really see a ton of T cells here.
They're generally T cell excluded, but every once in a while, a T cell makes it
into this anti-inflammatory hub.
And we wanted to understand what's different about the T cells in these hubs versus
the T cells in the other hubs in our samples.
So first we looked at the internal state of the CD8 T cells, so what genes are just
expressed in the T cells when they're in the hub versus not within the hub, and we
find that the T cells in the anti-inflammatory hub have a more
dysfunctional state.
We can then look at the clonality of the T cells that are in immune
effector hubs. In immune effector hubs, the CD8 T cells are generally, they belong
to an expanded clonotype, but the T cells in the anti-inflammatory
hubs belong to these singletons, so they're not expanded.
And then finally, we can ask what the ligand environments around
these T cells in the anti-inflammatory hub look like.
In other words, what's the external state program that's being used
by these anti-inflammatory hubs?
And what we see are a bunch of tissue repair and wound-healing ligands,
like SPP1, POSTN. There are some decoy receptors for cytokines, which
are immune suppressiveSo it seems like this anti-inflammatory
hub is activating this wound-healing response to
suppress the immune response and maybe support the tumor.
But then the question is, okay, so what's the relationship between these niches and
the tumor state?
So melanoma typically follows this dedifferentiation trajectory from this
melanocytic-like state to this more neural crest
state. It goes up its developmental hierarchy into, finally, this fully
undifferentiated state. And we see all three of these states in our samples that we
profiled. We also see some functional programs, like interferon-stimulated
program, a cell cycle program. And if we look at the interferon-stimulated program
for a second and we try to model the
interferon program score in the cancer
cells as a function of the density of each cell type
in its neighborhood,
we see that the immune effector hub cell types are
predictive of interferon signaling in the tumor cells.
So you can see here that these SIGLEC-10 macrophages co-localize really well with
cancer cells that are expressing this interferon program.
But then finally, we wanted to look at the neural crest cells, which are generally
associated with poor response in patients.
And what we see is that we identify a few different neural crest
programs
in our samples, and they really exist along this dedifferentiation
trajectory from a more melanocytic-like state to a more
undifferentiated, a more complete neural crest state.
And what's cool is we can look at the spatial neighborhoods
of cells along this trajectory.
So tumor-reactive CD8s are in yellow, SPP1 Macs are in purple, and then postin
fibroblasts are in green. And we see that along this trajectory
from a more melanocytic-like state to neural crest-like state, we see early on
there are lots of these CD8 T cells, but then eventually we see more
SPP1 macrophages, more postin fibroblasts
that are surrounding these more dedifferentiated cancer cells.
And to formalize this, we can see that CD8s are down along this trajectory,
while SPP1 Macs and postin fibroblasts are generally up.
And then finally, at the niche level,
if we model this trajectory score as a function of
the niche cell types in these cancer cell neighborhoods, we see that this
anti-inflammatory hub is the most predictive of a
higher neural crest trajectory, so a less differentiated, more
dedifferentiated tumor.
And then finally, we wanted to take the ligands or a couple of these ligands from
this tissue repair ligand program and put them on cancer cells and see what they're
doing. We find that postin,
which is this ECM ligand, when we put it on cancer cells, we see the cancer
cells dedifferentiate from this melanocytic-like state into
a more neural crest-y like state. And we put SPP1
on cancer cells, specifically cancer cells in this neural crest state.
We pre-treat with SPP1 and then later treat with interferon gamma, TNF alpha, and
some other immune-killing cytokines.
We see that SPP1 rescue is protecting cancer
cells against immune cytokine killing.
So to bring this all together, we see that tumor-reactive CD8 T cells in melanoma
are found more in these stem immunity hubs and immune effector hubs and are
generally excluded from the anti-inflammatory hubs.
The T cells that do enter the anti-inflammatory hubs are more dysfunctional.
They're less likely to be expanded, and they're surrounded by these tissue repair
ligands.
Immune effector hubs are predictive of interferon signaling, but anti-inflammatory
hubs are kind of correlated with this dedifferentiation trajectory.
And finally, we take some of these ligands from this tissue repair
ligand program and find that they're supporting this
dedifferentiation and immune evasion in
melanoma. So yeah. Thank you very much.
I'd like to thank Faye, Anir, Moshe, Alex, and the rest of the team
for this project, and I'm happy to take any questions.
If there are questions, you can go to the microphone.
I'll start.
Characterizing some of those T cells and those
anti-inflammatory hubs, do you see any
Tregs or?
Yeah, that's a great question. So actually,
the Treg... Okay, I think there's this ordering of which cell types
arise in the anti-inflammatory hubs along the dedifferentiation trajectory.
Yeah.
We see that the postin fibroblasts come first, then the
SPP1 macrophages, and then Tregs seem to come last, which is
interesting. And Tregs we find are generally associated with a fully
undifferentiated melanoma state, while kind of this anti-inflammatory hub
is maybe more associated with the neural crest intermediate state.
Yeah.
Thank you. Great presentation. My question is, if you use
immune checkpoint blockade-
Mm.
Would you see an improvement in dedifferentiation?
Hmm.
Oh, yeah. I guess usually there's this very interesting clinical phenomena,
I understand, where usually if you have a tumor before checkpoint
blockade, it's often more pigmented and kind of has its melanocytic
identity. But clinicians often see by eye that patients that relapse
or don't respond to immune checkpoint blockade, when they resect the
tumor that's left after checkpoint, it no longer is in this pigmented state, which
is a perfect marker for this dedifferentiation.
So I think this is a very well-known clinical phenomena, and
hopefully we're trying to provide the ligand programs that
might be promoting this dedifferentiation that clinicians have seen for a very long
time.
Great work.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much, Jackson.
Our next speaker is Matthew Ruane.
He's a Charles S.
Repsen Senior Fellow and Associate Research Scientist in the laboratory
of Dr.
Arpeyá in the Department of Microbiology and Immunology
at Columbia University in New York.
His talk is titled "Tumor-Specific Antibodies
Elicited by Engineered Bacteria Promote Bladder
Cancer Immunotherapy." The stage is yours.
Thank you.
Hi everyone. Thank you very much for coming today.
So yeah, my name is Matthew Juan. I'm a surgeon scientist.
I work at Columbia in Nick Arpeyá's lab, and our lab also
collaborates with Tal Danino.
Tal is a bioengineer at Columbia.
And so we engineer bacteria for cancer therapy.
So in this project, we asked a simple
question,
"Can we use bacteria to make bladder tumors
more responsive to PD-1 blockade?"
So bladder cancer is a common disease.
Its incidence is rising. Most of the patients we
see in the clinic have non-muscle invasive bladder cancer.
And for those patients,
we aim to preserve the bladder. Those patients have basically a pretty
good prognosis.
For the other group of patients with muscle invasive disease,
the tumors are much more aggressive, and so the treatment is
also
more aggressive.
So basically, that's how we treat these patients,
how we used to treat, because now the field is rapidly
evolving. But we used to treat these patients with a
cisplatin-based chemo before a radical cystectomy.
And,
as you can see here, those patients
still have a high risk of metastatic
progression.
So immunotherapy has been
developed first in the metastatic setting, and rapidly it
moved into the neoadjuvant space, so
before radical cystectomy.
And very recently, last November,
immune checkpoint blockade, so PD-1 and PD-L1 blockade, have
been approved
in combination with antibody drug conjugates or
chemotherapy before surgery and also after.
It's like a perioperative treatment.
But as a single agent, PD-1 and PD-L1
blockade give about 25% of
complete pathologic response. So there is a
clear signal, there is a clear activity for these drugs
in the neoadjuvant setting before surgery.
But 25% is not enough, and so the idea here
is to move that further.
The idea is to use bacteria, basically, to prime the tumor,
bladder tumors, before adding a PD-1 blockade to
sensitize those bladder tumors to PD-1 blockade.
So I'm going to
show you how we tested that.
So here you have two clinical trials.
And so those patients have been treated with
PD-1 blockade and PD-L1 blockade.
And so keep an eye on the blue curve.
You can see that patients with high
levels of CXCL13 have better response to
PD-1 and PD-L1 blockade.
CXCL13 is linked to B cells, and also it's
linked to lymphoid tissue development.
And when you look at the tumors of these patients, there is a clear
correlation between CXCL13 expression and the
presence of tertiary lymphoid structures.
So TLS are often described
as ectopic lymph nodes, so they're aggregates of
B cells and T cells. This one is particularly well
defined and mature. You can see also in the center, a
germinal center in this TLS.
So the idea was to
basically use the bacteria to deliver this chemokine in the
bladder of those mice.
And what has been shown also,
25 years ago, is that CXCL13 alone is
able to drive these tertiary lymphoid structures.
So here it's a mouse model, an experimental mouse model, and the
release of CXCL13 here in the pancreas of the
mice is able to recruit both B cells and T
cells. And you can see also this organization
with a B cell zone and a T cell zone.
CXCL13 is critical for B cell
maturation and
antibody production.
So we had our therapeutic payload,
CXCL13, but why did we choose
E. coli Nissle to deliver basically this chemokine?
And this idea comes from this clinical trial.
So it's a clinical trial we had in France.
Patients with bladder cancer received the
pembrolizumab before treatment.
And
we observed that patients with a high level of
anti-E. coli antibody, IgG antibodies in the blood before
treatment, had a better response to PD-1
blockade. Also, E. coli is the most frequent
pathogens found in the urine, and we could also
detect E. coli in bladder tumors.So it makes
sense to use this bacteria as a
system delivery approach.
So that's where our collaboration with Tal Danino
starts.
We use this probiotic strain of E. coli.
It's called the E. coli Nissle. So Nissle is
a probiotic strain of E. coli. It's a non-pathogenic
strain. You can find it and buy it actually online.
It's commercially available.
What makes our strain a little bit different is that we used this
synchronized lysis circuit. So it's
a quorum-sensing system.
It's integrated into the genome of the bacteria.
And so the way it works is that the bacteria
can grow until they reach a critical number.
A fraction of the bacteria lyse,
and they release immunogenic bacterial compounds and
also the therapeutic payload. But some bacteria remain
alive, and so they can grow again,
and release
more payloads.
So yeah, that's the schematic here to explain how it
works. So the bacteria are injected here in the
tumor. They grow.
A fraction of the bacteria
die and release their bacterial
compounds and their therapeutic payload.
Some bacteria can regrow because some of them remain alive.
And also we can track them in vivo because
we have this
tracking system, imaging system.
So we engineered this
E. coli Nissle to produce the chemokine CXCL13.
So we cloned the human chemokine and the mouse chemokine
in the plasmid, and we transformed the bacteria with the
plasmid that express those chemokines.
And actually in vitro, we saw a better activity using
mouse penisites. We saw a better activity with the human chemokine.
So we
moved forward with this
chemokine.
So the way we use it is that we deliver the
bacteria into the bladder, in bladder tumor-bearing mice,
also in orthotopic models. And so you can see here that
the bacteria remain in the bladder.
There is no spread to other organs.
What we also found is that
those bacteria specifically colonize bladder tumors.
They do not colonize
the normal tissue. So here we quantify the
CFU in
bladder tumor-free mice and bladder tumor-bearing mice, and you can see that you
can detect bacteria only in bladder
tumor-bearing mice.
We also confirmed that the bacteria were able to release
in vivo the chemokine by this
ELISA assay.
So next, we also tested
the toxicity profile of this
bacteria, and so we delivered the bacteria.
So basically, the way we do is we insert a catheter
into the bladder. It's a transurethral
catheterization, and we deliver the bacteria into the bladder.
So we repeated that four times, three days apart,
and we monitored the body weight over time.
There was no difference as compared to the PBS control group or the
bacteria empty vector. That's the blue one.
So basically, it says that this treatment is
safe.
And then we looked at the immune response.
So here the mice were treated with three
instillations of the engineered bacteria, the
one with the empty vector, no production of CXCL13,
BCG that we use for non-muscle invasive bladder cancer,
and the PBS control. And so what you can appreciate here is that we
saw this expansion of proliferative
CD4 T helper cells
upon exposure to this
strain of Nissle expressing CXCL13.
Those CD4 T cells were
upregulating co-stimulatory
receptor ICOS. They are also
activated. They express a high level of the PD-1 receptor.
So we thought it would be a good
combination to use with the PD-1 blockade.
So we combined basically this engineered bacteria with PD-1 blockade.
And for that, we tested that in this very
aggressive orthotopic model of bladder cancer.
So that's the MB49 model. So the
bladder cancer cells are instillated into the bladder, and we
started the treatment at day 10, so you can appreciate
the volume of the tumor in those mice.
It's a very bulky tumor.
And we combined that with PD-1 blockade
as soon as the treatment with the bacteria started.
And we saw a clear signal, a clear activity.
50% of those mice are cured as compared to
25% with PD-1 blockade alone. So we
improved the survival of those mice by two
times.And
so we also re-challenged those mice by implanting
the same
MB49 cell lines on both lungs of
those mice to test if they have a
memory
response. So you can see here that the
mice here, that's the control group, and the mice
who survived after the treatment.
Basically, there was no tumor growth.
The tumors did not grow back.
Mechanistically, we also found that
mice deficient with this subset of T cells, T follicular helper
cells, basically did not respond to the treatment.
So here it's a bone marrow chimera experiment, and mice
lacking these CD4 helper
T cells, T follicular helper cells,
here, that's the group here. They do not respond to this treatment.
So this suggests that those cells are critical to drive
the therapeutic effects of this combination therapy.
So our initial idea was to induce TLS, and so we looked at the
bladder wall. So here it's a section of the bladder wall.
The lumen is here. That's the urothelium,
the lamina propria, and the muscle.
So here it's an example of TLS with this aggregate of
CD4 T cells and B cells. But they were very
rare. We didn't find a lot.
So
the mechanism was not here, did not come from this
induction of TLS.
But then we looked at the draining lymph nodes, and there was a
clear signal in the draining lymph nodes.
So you can see here the mice received the bacteria plus the
PD-1 blockade, and you see this expansion of germinal
center B cells upon exposure to PD-1 blockade and
our engineered bacteria.
That's the quantification here.
And also we found an increased number of plasma cells,
suggesting that the B cells induced by this combination therapy
led to the differentiation into
antibody-secreting cells.
And so finally we looked at the circulating
antibodies. So we incubated the serum of those mice with
MB49 cells in vitro, and we
quantified the binding of IgG antibodies on the tumor
cells.
30 seconds.
And so you see these increased levels of tumor-specific
antibodies upon this combination therapy.
So that's our working model. We engineered
the probiotic strain of E. coli to make the
human chemokine CXCL13.
Upon intravesical delivery, those bacteria colonize bladder
tumors. They also migrate to the lymph nodes and induce
these germinal center responses with the production of
tumor-specific antibodies.
In the tumor, I didn't show that, but in the tumor, we saw also an
increased activity of CD8 cytotoxic T cells.
And with that, we cured
50% of the mice, two times more than a PD-1 blockade alone.
So thank you very much, and happy to take any questions.
Thank you. We have time for one quick question. Excellent presentation.
Really nice talk. I'm Leah Cook at the NCI.
So I was curious, do the macrophages contribute to this at all?
Because I'm just kind of wondering, do you see an infiltration with them when you
inject the E. coli into your bladder model?
Yeah, that's a great question. So we focused here mostly
on the adaptive immune response, T cells and B cell response.
We also looked
a little bit at the myeloid effect, and we saw an
increased
frequency of the macrophages called the Siglec-3
CR1 macrophages, and those macrophages also migrate
to the draining lymph nodes.
All right. Thank you.
Yeah.
Excellent work. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi. So we are excited to go to our next talk.
This is from Rosandra Tonia from the University of Chicago.
She is co-advised by Doctors Thomas Gajewski and Samantha
Rasenfield, and her seminar
talk will be on
integrating single-cell and spatial transcriptomics with mouse models of melanoma
and breast cancer to understand how tumor-associated macrophages suppress antitumor
immunity.
All yours. Go ahead.
Thank you for the introduction and for the opportunity to present some of my
PhD work here.
No disclosures.
So as many of you are probably aware, immunotherapy
has been proved to be effective in
treating multiple types of solid tumors.
However, there are still patients who do not respond well
and some who are experiencing relapse.
Studies from
tumors from responder and non-responder patients show the fact
that a key determinant for predicting immunotherapy
efficacy is the presence of CD8 positive T
cells.
Pan-cancer studies of immune transcriptional profiles
also show that tumors having a low signature
associated with trafficking of CD8 T cells into the tumors
also had expression of genes associated with
pro-tumor macrophages.Therefore,
understanding how these suppressive populations
affect the ability of CD8 T cells to infiltrate
and function properly inside the tumors is
necessary for expanding immunotherapy efficacy to a larger
fraction of patients.
Reprogramming anti-inflammatory tumor macrophages towards a
pro-inflammatory phenotype has the potential to remodel the whole
tumor microenvironment, leading to a more inflamed
signature that would promote recruitment of more CD8 T cells
and help maintain their function inside the tumor for longer.
So maybe one way of reprogramming would be to target new
molecules on myeloid cells that mediate immune suppression.
So our lab has previously identified multiple molecules
upregulated on dysfunctional cells isolated from
melanoma mouse tumors, and GPNMB was one of
them. Upon analysis of a human
single-cell RNA sequencing breast cancer data set, we
saw GPNMB as being upregulated on myeloid cells
from non-responder patients.
Out of all the immune cells from this data set, GPNMB
was preferentially expressed in myeloid cells, and
this was true among other data sets we
analyzed.
To further look into this in a mouse context, we started by
looking at in vitro bone marrow-derived macrophages
polarized towards a pro and anti-inflammatory phenotype and saw
that GPNMB was upregulated on the anti-inflammatory
subset.
So what is GPNMB? It is a type I transmembrane
glycoprotein. It can be cleaved by ADAM10
protease and be shed as a soluble protein, and literature
has proposed multiple receptors for it,
different based on the disease context.
So because we saw it as being upregulated on non-responder cancer
patients, we wondered whether it has any involvement in
tumor growth. And to do this, we generated full
knockout GPNMB mice and looked at tumor
growth in three different settings.
We saw significant tumor control and increased survival in
the B16-SIV subcutaneous model, in
an orthotopic model of breast cancer,
and in an experimental model of lung
metastasis. Endpoint
melanoma mouse tumors also had increased
numbers of CD8 positive T cells in the knockout, as well
as increased frequencies of memory
activated, but also CD39 positive and
TIM3 PD-1 double positive CD8 T cells.
The myeloid compartment was also affected, showing increased
numbers of the pro-inflammatory macrophages and
monocytes.
So we wanted to further investigate which cell
types are affected the most by this GPNMB
knockout, and for this, we performed single-cell RNA
sequencing on the immune compartment and saw that the
most affected cell types were the macrophages, followed by the
T cells.
After further analyzing the macrophage compartment, we
identified eight different subsets, two of which
were significantly different in terms of proportions between the wild
type and the knockout. One subtype expressing
CXCL10 gene and other pro-inflammatory genes was
expanded in the knockout, while another one expressing mitochondrial
genes, which are known to be associated with
oxidative phosphorylation, was expanded in the wild type.
Even though GPNMB is only expressed by
one anti-inflammatory subset of those macrophages, two
of them seem to be the most different in terms
of transcriptional changes between the wild type and the knockout,
suggesting a possible role for GPNMB on
neighboring cells.
So these two subtypes of macrophages we saw as being the
most
changed by the knockout in terms of the number of differentially expressed
genes, express C1Q genes and SPP1
gene respectively, and both of them, upon the
GPNMB knockout, upregulated many
interferon-induced genes and downregulated
several lipid genes.
We wanted to test whether these genes we saw as
being upregulated in the knockout have any
predictive value in human data. So we created a gene
score using those genes here and saw that
this gene signature was increased in inflamed
tumors from breast cancer patients.
So because we saw all these lipid genes downregulated in the
knockout, we wanted to test this in another way.
So we looked at fatty acid uptake in vivo by those
tumor macrophages and saw that both pro and
anti-inflammatory subsets
from the tumors grown in the knockout mice showed decreased fatty
acid uptake. So literature is suggesting
that lipid-loaded macrophages have anti-inflammatory
properties in multiple disease models.
So this result is consistent with the idea that the GPNMB knockout is
able to shift the phenotype of the macrophages from an
anti to a pro-inflammatory type.
We also tested the ability of macrophages isolated
from tumors to suppress in vitro activated CD8 positive
T cells and saw that the knockout macrophages suppress
them
less.Um, measured by increased
proliferation in the T cells, as well as increased frequencies
of CD8 T cells secreting interferon gamma, TNF
alpha, and granzyme B.
Since our data indicate that the knockout affects
both macrophages and T cells, and that these two cell
types seem to be involved in some sort of crosstalk, we
wanted to see whether the tumor control in the knockout
is
dependent on T cells. So we
saw that when depleting all T cells using an anti-Thy1
antibody, the tumor control from the knockout was
completely lost. While when only depleting CD8 T
cells, or when we only blocked interferon gamma, the
tumor control was only partially lost.
Also, in tumors, the increase we were
seeing at baseline in the knockout in the pro-inflammatory
macrophages was completely eliminated when we
depleted CD8 T cells.
This arguing that absence of GPNMB
is enabling the CD8 T cells to maybe push the
macrophage phenotype.
So,
due to all these changes in the immune compartment we were seeing, we
wondered whether a knockout of this gene in the
hematopoietic compartment only would lead to tumor
control. And to do this, we made
GPNMB floxed mice that we crossed with the Vav1 Cre mice,
and unexpectedly we saw that there was no tumor control
in either of the models that we were using.
To look at the hematopoietic compartment in a different way, and
also be able to distinguish the non-immune compartment from the
immune compartment, we made bone marrow chimeras in which
either the host or the bone marrow had the gene deletion.
And our results show that absence of
GPNMB from the host led to tumor control, while
when GPNMB was absent from the bone marrow, there was no tumor
control.
The tumors grew slightly faster. So our
next hypothesis for this scenario was that either
a non-immune compartment or
macrophages that are non-bone marrow derived, tissue resident,
are targeted by GPNMB and important for tumor
control.
So to test this, we crossed our floxed
mice with the LysM Cre mice
and were able to see that when
GPNMB is absent from cells targeted by the LysM
promoter, we see tumor control. And because the
LysM Cre is known to target some tissue-resident macrophages
while the Vav1 Cre doesn't,
we think that this result is suggesting that GPNMB
knockout is targeting some non-bone marrow derived tissue-resident
macrophages, and this leads to tumor control.
So in conclusion, knockout of host-derived GPNMB
leads to a shift in two anti-inflammatory
subsets of macrophages from tumors,
and knockout of GPNMB in cells targeted by the LysM promoter and not
by the Vav1 promoter is sufficient to enhance tumor control,
suggesting a role for non-bone marrow derived tissue-resident
macrophages.
Thank you.
We have time for a few questions.
Hi, great talk.
Jiang from Mount Sinai. Quick two questions for you.
Are these GPNMB positive macrophages also Trem2 positive
in your data set?
Yes.
Okay.
They are.
And the second question-
And some are SPP1 positive, too.
Okay. And the second question is, have you ever done a bone marrow chimer
instead of your GPNMB knockout to kind of really resolve this
stromal contribution of GPNMB versus resident
macrophages?
So,
I did show, right? That we did a bone marrow chimera in which either
the host or the bone marrow was deleted.
Gotcha.
And we saw tumor control when the host was the knockout.
Sorry, I think I meant like, I know it's really difficult and-
Yeah, sorry. I didn't--
It's like an embryonic stage. Like-
Oh, embryonic stage.
Yeah.
No, we haven't done that yet.
Okay. Got it. Thanks.
Thank you.
Great talk. I have a question. In this melanoma model,
what percentage of macrophages in the tumor are
non-bone marrow derived and tissue
resident?
So yeah. That's a very good question.
Not many are tissue resident. From the bone marrow
chimeras, it looked like the ones that survived their
irradiation are like 5% or
something around that.
Thank you.
I had a question here,
right here. Me.
Sorry.
You highlighted about
lipids. Have you tried to take these macrophages out, do some
lipid experiments with them, see how they take up lipids after
GPNB
deletion?
We haven't done any in vitro, only the in
vivo where we inject the fatty acid, the C16
fatty acid-
Okay
... and we saw decreased uptake. But yeah, that's a
very good idea.
Thank you.
Yeah, one more question right here.
Great work. Is there any way to block this molecule
in vivo? Any inhibitors or anything in a model that is
not a knockout, but just an inhibitor of this molecule?
Do you see any results with that?
We haven't done that yet. But yeah, we are working
on making an inhibitor for it.
And this gene is conserved in humans, correct?
Yes, it is.
Okay.
Great.
All right. Great talk. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is
Dr. Ma, who's an assistant professor in the Departments of
Pathology and Laboratory Medicine and Bioengineering
at University of Pennsylvania. His presentation is
Vaccine Stimulation of Bystander T cells in
the Lymph Node Unexpectedly Promotes
Tumor-Specific Host Immunity to Regress Solid
Tumors. Liam, over to you.
Thank you. Thank you for the introduction and the opportunity to share
our unpublished work here. And today I'm actually going
to discuss some sort of unexpected phenomenon
regarding the bystander T cell responding to a vaccine stimulation,
which can regress multiple solid tumors.
And this, we think, can be potentially one step towards this
off-the-shelf cancer vaccine or cell therapy.
So probably many of you have seen this paper, and I'm not sure Adam's here,
but he basically showed this SARS-CoV-2 mRNA
vaccine can unexpectedly sensitize solid tumors to
checkpoint inhibitors. And however, there are also
other sporadic case reports showing just receiving the
SARS-CoV-2 vaccine or maybe some other vaccines, some patients can
experience spontaneous tumor regression.
And importantly,
if you actually read carefully, this spontaneous
tumor regression occurs only after booster doses of vaccination.
And in immunology, if you know that typically if the T cell responds,
they will have the prime and boost.
Their response to the prime and booster vaccine is totally different.
In the booster vaccine, they will have much higher magnitude and much stronger
response. So this means this booster vaccination to SARS-CoV-2 can
potentially really ramp up these
SARS-CoV-2 specific T cells and triggering this bystander T cell
activation and tumor regression.
So there happened to be such a rare case from the University of Pennsylvania, where
I'm from, and this is from Alexander Huang.
In this patient who received this first dose of vaccine on
April 5th, 2021, and now...
Well, sorry. So actually, received it before that, but actually, when he
came to the clinic to discover this, he had this melanoma.
And then after a month, he received the second dose of the COVID vaccine.
Then slowly after another month, the tumor actually melts away.
So Alex has done some pathology analysis, found there's huge infiltration
of T cells into the tumor bed and also the lymph node.
And so there could be this SARS-CoV-2 specific T cell response to the booster
vaccine that may be associated with tumor regression.
So we happen to have this independent finding in our preclinical
models.
And we actually found this using our synthetic vaccine boosting CAR
T cells. And the CAR T cell, they are tumor irrelevant.
And then somehow we saw this drastic tumor regression
in multiple tumor models, including PDAC, melanoma, and breast cancer.
But I will be mostly focusing on PDAC model for discovering the
mechanism.
So previously, we basically developed this vaccine.
So for now, I'll briefly describe how this vaccine works.
So we developed this synthetic vaccine called amphiphile vaccine, which is
basically a lipid polymer carrying the ligand recognized by the CAR.
And this lipid polymer can traffic to the lymph node very efficiently and
label the dendritic cells. So basically letting the dendritic cells
presenting the ligand recognized by the CAR without it going through this
internal processing and then going through this peptide MHC presentation,
which can only be recognized by conventional T cells through the TCR
interaction.
So this we already published a couple of years ago and show this vaccine
boosting the tumor-specific T cells.
We can increase CAR T number, persistence, enhancing their activity,
and tumor infiltration into solid tumor, ultimately really cure some solid tumor in
the preclinical models. So this was done
a couple of years ago, but now we are thinking actually whether we
can use this CAR as the vaccine receptor, and then
to essentially boost potentially any therapeutic T cell in vivo.
But first of all, we introduce this CAR, and now we are
using a CAR recognizing fluorescent molecule because it's more like generic
CAR. We can use the generic amphiphilic vaccine to stimulate the
T cells. So here what we did was we introduced this CAR into
the GP100 specific pML T cells, making this T cell
bispecific. So this way we can essentially benchmark our synthetic vaccine
against this conventional vaccine, which going through either the CAR or the TCR.
If we transfer these bispecific T cells into mice, then
vaccinate with either our synthetic vaccine or the GP100
vaccine, we can see comparable expansion.
So this shows vaccine through the CAR or the TCR
at least work comparably in this adoptive cell transfer setting.
And we can faithfully use the CAR as a vaccine receptor,
because the physical CAR doesn't recognize tumor, which it served as essentially a
generic vaccine receptor. And now we are switching to this
tumor targeting setting. We're using the physical CAR as the generic vaccine
receptor, but now we're putting a separate CAR that can recognize tumor
to essentially make this platform more generalizable.
But as a control, we do not include in the tumor targeting CAR, which is the
methylcellulose targeting CAR.And then we essentially
tried this concept in this PDAC model, which is naturally
expressed in mouse mesothelin. And then once we did this, as you can see
in multiple of this control setting, it does not have any effect on the tumor
growth. And then these are all expected.
But then once we are using this vaccine boosting, this mesothelin VEC BI specific
CAR, now we can see drastic tumor regression. So this is also kind of expected.
What's unexpected is if we're using this VEC vaccine, boosting the
VEC CAR T, which was initially designated as negative control, we
also see drastic tumor regression.
And as you can see in vitro, this VEC CAR T does not kill tumor at all. Right?
And this essentially happens also in 24 hours, really rapid. Right?
This is a really kind of striking phenomenon.
And then of course, it was based on caliper measurement.
Then I was asking my postdoc, "Can we generate some luciferase reporter line to
see its really impact on the tumor cell themselves?" And indeed, we
saw comparable
results. Right? This essentially huge reduction and rapid reduction of the
tumor volume within 24 hours of the
vaccination.
And of course, it applies to multiple solid tumors, as I mentioned in the
beginning. And in the melanoma setting, which generally have higher
mutation burden, and we even able to cure two out of
five mice. And also in the breast tumor model, we're also able to significantly
slow down tumor progression.
And so importantly, when we were mismatching the vaccine and the
CAR, and we lost the efficacy. So this really shows,
so we have to letting the T cell respond to the vaccine stimulation.
And also we can switch the CAR and the vaccine, but if we had to
switch them together, then we can still see the comparable tumor regression.
Right? Because none of these CAR T cells recognizing the PDAC model
at all, so this essentially tell this is bystander effect.
Right? So what could be the mechanism?
And now again, I'm focusing on the PDAC model to show the mechanism.
And so first of all, we showed if we deplete the CAR T cell, because we knew
it doesn't recognize tumor. So if we deplete them at different time,
it actually give us different results.
So if we deplete them 24 hours after the vaccination, we almost immediately lost
the tumor control. But if we deplete them three days later after the
vaccination, then there's no impact.
The tumor regression remains. Right?
So this really show this tumor irrelevant CAR T
actually serve as a helper really to respond to vaccine, changing
something in vivo.
And our hypothesis is this process actually create a
modulation. And because the vaccine stimulating T cells happened in the lymph
node, it's likely have this distal bison effect. Right?
When we analyze the cytokine and chemokine in the tumor microenvironment and the
lymph node, and we did see a significant
upregulation of different pro-inflammatory cytokines.
And so we did analyze a number of the immune cells in the tumor
microenvironment,
with or without a vaccination. And we don't see any change in number.
But the phenotype, as you can see here, with vaccination boosting the
tumor irrelevant CAR T cells, we can see significant increase
of the activation markers in both T cells and also DC in the
tumor microenvironment. And also tumor cell also have elevated MHC class
I and also MHC class II expression. Right?
So this really show this distal effect can remodel the tumor microenvironment.
So we also collect the serum from the mice at different
time point. And what you can see here, it's only 24 hours after vaccination,
you can see huge spike of the pro-inflammatory cytokine.
So this is not a really a cytokine storm.
It's rapid release and then quickly
disappears. And the important thing that there's two major cytokines like
interferon gamma and CCL2, which was previously shown by my collaborator, Gregory
Beatty, they can cooperate to redirect monocyte to degrade
fibrosis, which is the major shield around PDAC tumor. Right?
So when we did a histology analysis and we saw exactly that
this fibroid capsule got shrinked very rapidly within 24 hours.
So over time, if you analyze this immune cells in the
tumor seven days after this vaccine boosting, and you can actually see
significant increased endogenous immune cell infiltration into the tumor.
Right? So this really shows it's like the initial remodulation of the tumor
microenvironment, like removing this shield and can promote
endogenous immune cell infiltration, and which can potentially leads to tumor
regression.
And so now we know that multiple cytokine have been significantly elevated
within 24 hours. Now we start blocking different pro-inflammatory cytokine.
These are all three. Those are the major ones.
And so interestingly, although blocking all of them, you can see the effect.
But when you're blocking the interferon gamma, you can see almost complete loss of
the therapeutic efficacy. Right?
And so the important thing of blocking the interferon gamma, you also kind of
downregulate the MHC class I expression.
These are on the tumor cells. And once we're using this B2m knockin PDAC,
which lost its MHC class I expression, and we definitely see the loss of
the tumor regression control.
And so this also tells us this is through host T cells and likely
CD8 T cells, which can recognize the antigen presented by MHC class I.
And then we just move on to continue investigating if this really T
cell. Right? That was our speculation, but now these are experimental proof.
So first of all, we used either wild-type mice or Reg1 knockin mice.
In the Reg1 knockin mice, they do not have endogenous lymphocyte. Right?
Either they don't have B cell, and they don't have B cell and T cells.
So in this mouse model, as you can see, the therapeutic efficacy initially we saw
in the wild-type mice, completely gone 100%.
And then we move on to this Beta3 knockin mice background.
So in this mouse genetic background, they have T cell, they have B cell, but
the T cell cannot be educated by this cross-presenting dendritic cell,
which can tell the T cell, okay, there's a tumor, and then they can recognize
tumor. So in this model, we also see complete loss of the
efficacy. So this mean the T cell cannot recognize tumor.
It's not because the T cell simply releasing the cytokine or
granzymes that can kill any T cell surrounding it.
We have to through this antigen specificity.And finally, we showed
you this, like in the perfect knock-on mice, the therapeutic efficacy is also
completely gone. So this means the T cells have to recognize the tumor and be
cytotoxic.
So finally, we showed that the interferon gamma can use the
PD-L1, which is checkpoint in the tumor cells.
And if you combine with anti-PD-L1, you can further
deepen the tumor regression in this process.
Yeah. So now this is the conclusion, and our hypothesis is that
this vaccine stimulation of the CAR T cells, even though they are tumor irrelevant,
but they can have this rapid immune modulation in the tumor
microenvironment, which can distally remodel the tumor microenvironment,
and then eventually leading to degradation of fibrosis, promoting immune cell
infiltration, and most importantly, they can reinvigorate the preexisting
tumor-specific T cells, making them to fighting against tumor again.
Yeah, so this is some analogy. I'm sure many of you have seen "Game of Thrones." So
the T cells can fight by themselves, which may not work that well, but if they're
charged with the vaccine, which is fire, and now you can kill the white walkers.
And all you can just like using the bison effect, which is flame, right?
Yeah, this is my team, and this was mostly led by Thomas
and Ryan, and also this is my collaborators and funding source. Yeah.
Thank you.
Excellent work. Any questions from the audience?
All right, go ahead.
Hi. Great talk. I was curious if you were able to do any of these
experiments of the CAR Vax combined strategy without
lymphodepleting prior to CAR adoptive transfer, and
if so, did that change the results at all?
Yeah. So I guess you're questioning whether we have done this in the
non-lymphodepleted mice, right?
So we did, and the effect is very interesting.
So within twenty-four hours, we still see the deep tumor control, right?
But the tumor rapidly rebounds. Different from what we saw right now,
we have much deeper tumor regression over time.
And I think there are many reasons there.
Usually the lymphodepletion is important to removing the cytokine sink,
which may be critical for maintaining even the endogenous T cell
function within the tumor microenvironment. But we are still investigating that.
So thank you.
Excellent talk. I have two general questions in regards to the
discovery of these
tumors relevance vaccine inducing antitumor response.
The first question is that,
what do you think about personalized vaccines where it's designed specifically
for humans and it's likely to be less immunogenic than
COVID-19?
What is the trade-off? Just what is the implications?
This is my first naive questions. And yeah.
Yeah.
Second one is, how much is the contribution of LNP to the overall
immunity that you have seen? Maybe not in your case, but in the COVID-19 case.
Yeah. Let me answer the first one. So I think the new antigen vaccine
is highly personalized vaccine, and it's going to be
very effective if the new antigen can be efficient identified, and
if there are enough precursor T cells in the body responding to this
vaccine. Right? So what we discovered here, which I didn't have time to show more
data, is that we need sufficient number of T cells responding to the
vaccine. If you're below certain threshold, this therapy doesn't
work. But considering the number of T cells we adopted
transferred in this lymphodepleted setting and the overall
frequency is still much, much higher than the new antigen-specific T cells
in the non-lymphodepleted setting in patient. Right?
So that's, I think,
this tells us the mechanism and if this can work, but
also tells us the potential parameter we have to think about in the future, how to
implement this in a more translatable setting, right?
So can you remind me of the second question?
Just in term of the COVID-19 cases-
Yeah
... how much is contribution of the LNPs itself?
Yeah. So,
that I don't have much experience in, but I can see, in the
COVID-19 mRNA vaccine setting, that's their predominant trigger,
this innate immune response. And that they have shown this interferon
alpha is mediating that effect. But in our setting, as you
can see, we essentially bypassed this innate immune response.
And the T cell, they're pre-activated.
Essentially, we are mimicking the booster response as the T cell responding to
booster vaccines. Right? Because in the prime vaccine, the prime dose
usually will activate this naive T cells, making them more activated,
ready to receiving this booster dose. Right?
We essentially bypass that step, directly mimicking this phenomenon we
saw in the patient experience spontaneous tumor regression, their T cell response
to booster vaccination. Right? So this is more adaptive T cell response
and instead of the innate response. Right.
Thank you very much.
Hi. Thank you so much.
This is really cool. I'm really curious about
mirroring sort of effects that we see in, like, the abscopal effect-
Yeah
... where we're having a distal tumor response,
seeing metastatic improvement. And I'm curious if there's
a conserved mechanism of antigen independent,
I don't know, pro-inflammatory systemic, and if you've looked at this in the
context of abscopal.
We have not, because what we've been seeing here is it's almost already a systemic
fact. And as you probably remember, in one of my slides, I showed that if you
collect the serum from the lymph node and the tumor, you can see increase of
this cytokine and the chemokines in the plasma is also the same.
It almost means even though we are stimulating T cell using the vaccine in the
lymph node, but this pouring from the cytokine and chemokines, they still
travel systemically or maybe even having this local effect.
So it really doesn't matter, obviously, at least in our setting, whether
tumor is a primary tumor or distal tumor.
But so far, we haven't really dived into that yet,
but we will. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Yeah. Thank you.
Our next talk will be from Audrey May.
Audrey May is a PhD candidate in immunology working in the laboratory of Dr.
Crystal Mackall at Stanford University School of Medicine.
Her talk is titled "IL-18-secreting CAR T cells uncover
divergent immune mechanisms of antigen-heterogeneous solid
tumor clearance." Audrey, please take the podium.
Great. Thank you. As mentioned, my name is Audrey May.
I'm a PhD candidate working in the lab of Dr.
Crystal Mackall at Stanford University, and today I'll be presenting my
project titled "IL-18 CARs Uncover Divergent Immune
Mechanisms of Antigen-Heterogeneous Tumor Clearance."
So I've nothing to disclose.
But as many of us know, solid tumors present a major obstacle for CAR
T efficacy due to their heterogeneous antigen expression.
Often after CAR T-cell therapy treatment, these tumor
cells will completely down-regulate or lose the antigen expression,
a phenomenon known as antigen escape.
Some of the solutions that the CAR T field has come up with to deal with these
limitations are the engineering of multi-specific CARs,
which can target multiple tumor-associated antigens simultaneously.
However, this approach presents some limitations,
one being the challenging engineering it presents, the
identification of multiple safe targets, and as well as the reduced
CAR T-cell efficacy it faces.
Another approach to dealing with these heterogeneous tumors
is engaging endogenous immune responses along with
CAR T treatment. So,
an innate immunity or immunity in general is
divided into innate and adaptive arms.
And so NK cells, macrophages, and neutrophils have been widely
implicated as innate effectors being able to clear
or at least control tumors to some extent, whereas the adaptive arm
is made up of primarily T cells and B cells, T cells requiring
dendritic cells to prime them against a tumor-specific
response. So although many of these immune cells have been
implicated as important for heterogeneous tumor clearance, their
mechanism still remains slightly unclear, at least in the CAR T therapy
implication.
So our goal here is to study the biology of heterogeneous
tumor clearance using cytokine-producing CAR
Ts that are capable of inducing endogenous immune responses.
So to do this, I picked three existing cytokine-producing CAR
Ts previously published, and the first one I
worked with is the decoy-resistant IL-18-secreting
CARs. So this IL-18 molecule was engineered to overcome
cytokine sinks,
but they're still able to signal through the endogenous IL-18 receptor.
So IL-18 is known to activate lymphoid cell
populations as well as increase interferon gamma
secretion from those cells.
The next cytokine-secreting CAR I chose was IL-36 secretion
CARs, and this cytokine is known to
activate myeloid cell populations and increase their ability to
present antigens. And the third I wanted to choose was FLT3
ligand-secreting CARs, and this cytokine is more
targeted towards dendritic cells, increasing their expansion,
survival, and function overall.
So with all these distinct modulators of immunity, we sought to determine the
relative contribution of innate versus adaptive immunity
and CAR-mediated tumor clearance using immunocompetent mouse models.
So to do this, we decided to use
B16-F10 OVA-expressing tumor cell
lines and then further engineered them to express a CAR target antigen.
In this case, we're using human CD19.
So these heterogeneous tumors were modeled
by challenging wild-type black
6 mice with a heterogeneous tumor of 80%
antigen-positive tumor cells and then 20% negative.
Six days after the challenge, these mice were lympho-depleted with
cyclophosphamide, and then the day after, CARs were
adoptively transferred into these mice at three million CARs per mouse.
Then we assessed
immune cell populations as well as their activity at two separate time
points throughout the experiment.
So this is what the CAR looks like, which was expressed into
murine T cell populations using retroviral
integration, and the CAR had a anti-human CD19
scFv with CD28 co-stimulatory domains,
followed by a 2A element to separate for the expressed cytokines.
And so we assessed the expression levels of each of these CARs across
treatment groups by looking at CD19 CAR expression.
And as you can see, it's relatively consistent across each group.
So jumping straight into the heterogeneous tumor clearance curves,
what we can see strikingly is that these IL-18-secreting CARs
were able to demonstrate superior heterogeneous tumor control
compared to all the other treatment groups.
And if we look on the right-hand side at the individual tumor growth curves, what
you can appreciate is that a number of these mice were able to completely clear
those heterogeneous tumors, although several of them did start to reoccur at the
end.
We then assessed the B16 tumor cells that were
remaining at this terminal endpoint.
And what we saw is that when we look at human CD19 expression,
all of these CARs were able to completely clear their target
antigen tumor cell populations, while what remained at
the end were antigen-negative tumor cells.
So to get a better idea as to what's contributing to this superior tumor
control, we turn to absolute number of CAR Ts
across a number of tissues within these mice.So to our
surprise, the IL-18 secreting CARs demonstrated low persistence
within the tumor-draining lymph nodes and tumor of these mice, even though they
showed better tumor clearance. Whereas there was a large accumulation,
surprisingly, within the spleen of these mice.
When we look at the terminal time point, we could see that there was a low
number, again, of these IL-18 secreting CARs within the tumor,
but then we lost those CARs within the spleen, indicating a very poor
persistence compared to all other CAR treatment groups.
So then we wanted to turn to the endogenous T cell populations.
And what we saw is that although there was no change in terms of absolute
number of endogenous T cells across these treatment groups, at least in the
spleen and tumor tissues,
what we did see that was striking was an upregulation of CD8s versus
CD4s in the IL-18 secreting CARs, which is consistent with
existing literature.
When we looked at the phenotype of these endogenous CD8s, what we saw in the
IL-18 secreting CARs was an enrichment of effector memory
phenotypes,
as well as an upregulation of activation/exhaustion markers such
as PD-1 and CD39.
We confirmed these results through bulk RNA sequencing by
taking bulk T cells isolated from tumor-draining lymph nodes and
spleens of these treated mice, and then looking at gene profiles.
What you can see is that in general, across both of these
groups, is that in the IL-18 secreting CARs, there was an
increase in the cytotoxic effector genes, cycling genes, and interferon axis
related genes, while there was a decrease in stemness or persistent markers.
So then we wanted to quantify if these endogenous CD8s presented
any antitumor response. So to do this, we turned to an interferon
gamma ELISpot assay, and this allows you to detect interferon gamma
secretion on an individual cell basis.
So to do this, I harvested T cells from both the spleen and tumor-draining
lymph nodes,
and then stimulated those T cells with a peptide pool that's MHC class one
restricted,
and then measured the T cell response to those peptides via the
ELISpot plate.
And so this peptide pool is consisting of
well-established B16 tumor derived peptides as well as
OVA, almost acting as a tumor neoantigen in this case.
So in order to quantify these results, I took the
peptide stimulated wells, subtracted out the background seen
in the negative control,
and then normalized based on a million cells.
And so the ELISpot results here are split between
the tissue of origin, but what you can see clearly is that there's a
large tumor reactive CD8 population
observed more so in the IL-36 gamma secreting CARs as well as the
CAR-only groups, whereas there's way less observed in the
IL-18 secreting CAR treated group, to our surprise.
And if we connect these ELISpot results back to the tumor growth
curves,
although IL-36 gamma secreting CARs and the CAR-only
control demonstrated more tumor reactive CD8s, they also
had poorer tumor control in general.
So I wanted to confirm some of these results by testing heterogeneous
tumor clearance in the absence of adaptive immunity.
So to do this, I challenged again using our heterogeneous tumor model
in wild type mice, but also compared to Rag1 knockout mice
lacking B cells and T cells.
So what I could see in the CAR-only control is that relative to the wild
type, the
Rag knockout mice quickly lost control of that primary tumor,
indicating a dependence on adaptive immunity present.
Whereas for the IL-18 secreting CARs, the difference in terms of
tumor clearance between the wild type and Rag knockout
was relatively little or nonexistent, indicating an independence
on adaptive immunity.
So considering all of this, we still had the question of what is contributing to
this antitumor response. So this brought our attention to
understanding what frequencies of immune cell populations exist within these
mice. And so when we look at the tumor-draining lymph node tissue, we can
see a clear decrease in T cell populations,
while there's a clear increase in myeloid cell frequencies in these IL-18
secreting CARs.
Then when we look in the spleen, although there's no change in absolute T cell
numbers, what we can see are other lymphocyte populations
are decreased, such as B cells and then K cells.
And then when we look at the myeloid cell populations, we can see a great increase
in absolute counts of neutrophils as well as macrophages.
So then we wanted to look at the phenotype of these myeloid cells, which were
isolated from the spleens of these treated
mice and then sequenced via bulk RNA sequencing.
And what you can see is that generally, these myeloid cells in these IL-18
secreting CAR treated mice generated an increase in interferon gamma
responsive genes, antigen presentation machinery, as well as
complement mediated genes.
So considering all of this, we wanted to look at the role neutrophils play
mediating this IL-18 CAR treated tumor control.
So we did this by taking our same model, but this time depleting
neutrophils by treating with anti-Ly6G antibody.
And what you can see is that there's relatively no difference in
tumor control, indicating that these IL-18 secreting CARs are
independent of neutrophil activity.
So in summary, our model is able to define the contributions of
innate versus adaptive immunity in controlling of these heterogeneous
tumors. IL-18 outperformed controls as well as
the IL-36 and FLT3 ligand secreting CARs
in controlling these tumors.Despite superior tumor
control, these IL-18 CARs induced inferior
persistence and reduced adaptive
immune responses while I-36 gamma and control CARs
induced the highest level of adaptive immune responses but had worse tumor
clearance.
Alternatively, IL-18 seemed to induce substantial myeloid cell
expansion and activation, although neutrophils did not seem to be required
for this IL-18-mediated control.
Instead, we postulate that macrophages are probably major
mediators of this IL-18-mediated clearance, and we're
currently doing other studies to further support that.
But ultimately, approaches designed to maximize killing of
heterogeneous tumors via innate immune cells may hold promise for
future CAR T cell therapy development.
Thank you. I'll take questions.
I'll start here at the panel.
MHC
changes with IL-18. Do you all measure that?
Yes, I did, within the tumor cells. Yeah.
Oh, do you mean on the tumor cells or other
immune cells?
I was referring to the immune cells.
Oh, immune cells. Okay. Yeah. So all the myeloid cells tend to upregulate
MHC class II,
and then there is changes, at least in MHC class I expression on the tumor cells-
Right
... with the IL-18 because there's more interferon gamma secretion, so they do
upregulate MHC class I expression as well.
Does it get down-regulated? I don't know how far out the experiments went,
but sometimes the tumors can upregulate it and then it
gets down-regulated. There have been studies looking at stabilizing
antibodies to keep it there. Do you see any changes in the tumor cells?
I don't know how far out you went with the experiment.
Yeah. I haven't shown that, but I do see
changes, especially because as these experiments go on, the
IL-18 CARs, as I mentioned, persist quite poorly.
Okay.
So then you see a lot of rewiring after those CARs are
absent from the system, and so MHC class I expression will start to decrease
on those tumor cells and look more similar to the untreated
groups.
Understood. You had a question right there.
Hi.
Could your results be related to the fact that macrophages
express higher IL-18 receptor,
so it might be more sensitive to IL-18?
Yes. So they express more, but I would say the primary
cells that express it would be NK cells and T cells more
preferentially. Instead, I think it's more of
a
peripheral activation phenotype that you get just from the large
amount of interferon gamma signaling you see in the mice.
Thanks.
Hi. I have two questions-
Mm-hmm
... if I have time. First, did you look at any other models?
Just trying to disentangle if it's model specific.
Yeah. I've looked at
NC38 models as well,
which it looks still similar. I wanted to use a pretty
aggressive model like the B16, that also
has really well-characterized peptides
to prime against. So, besides those two
tumor models, I haven't tested anything else, but it is consistent across those.
And then my next question is, maybe I just missed it, but did you look at
cytokine alone, so engineered just to express IL-18 in the
absence of CAR?
Yeah. I don't have those here. I do have those,
but basically, I
see a little bit of tumor control, I think just from
the general inflammation you get, just from the presence of the
IL-18 driving more of an interferon gamma release.
But,
because these tumors are so aggressive, it's just like a small blip, and then the
tumors start to grow out pretty rapidly, so the timing is
difficult to get anything meaningful.
Thanks.
Mm-hmm.
All right. Thank you so much, Audrey.
Our last speaker is Dr. Hyunsoo Cho.
He's a hematologist oncologist at Seoul National
University Hospital in South Korea.
His talk is titled "Emergency Myelopoiesis
Drives Immunosuppressive Monocyte Programming in
Lymphoma Associated Secondary
Hemophagocytic Lymphohistiocytosis."
The floor is yours.
Thank you for the kind introduction.
My name is Hyunsoo Cho, and I'm a physician scientist from Seoul National
University Hospital.
First of all, I'd like to thank the organizing committee for giving me the
opportunity to share our work. And today, I'd like to
discuss the emergency myelopoiesis drives immunosuppressive monocyte
programming in lymphoma-associated secondary
hemophagocytic lymphohistiocytosis, so-called
HHH.
So, HHH is a life-threatening
hyperinflammatory syndrome caused by the dysregulation of the
hyperactivity of the immune system,
and it is generally categorized into the primary or secondary HHH.
So primary HHH is a pediatric genetic disease
caused by the defect in the lymphocytes function, such as
pyferrin or UNC13D, STX11 or
STSBP2.
In contrast, secondary HHH occurs in adults, and it
is caused by the infection, malignancy or autoimmune disease.
So when we look at the causes of the secondary HHH, about 30% of the
secondary HHH is caused by the hematologic malignancies such
as lymphoma or leukemia. However, the solid tumor proportion is very
low, so it is very distinct phenotype.
However, the pathophysiology of the secondary HHH is less
understood.And recently, with the advent of the CAR T cells
or bispecific antibody therapies, we acknowledge that the
immunodefective cell-associated HHH-like syndrome is also the
problem, and up to 30% of the CD22 CAR-T
recipients suffer from the IE-CHS, so we
should focus on this disease.
Among the causes of the secondary HHH, lymphoma-associated HHH
has the worst prognosis.
When they analyzed more than 500 patients with the
lymphoma-associated HHH cases, you can see the high
mortality and early mortality. And even patients could not
receive treatment because they were too ill to receive treatment.
And without treatment, the median survival was less than one month.
And I also saw a patient with the secondary HHH, a patient
who suffered from the lymphoma-associated cases, but the
mechanism of the secondary HHH was not clear.
When we look into the pathophysiology of the primary HHH, we can see
that when there's a trigger, like a virus, the dendritic cells
process the peptide and present the peptide to the CD8+ cytotoxic
T cells. And CD8+ T cell expansion leads
to secretion of interferon gamma.
However, because of the cytotoxic defect,
dendritic cells are not cleared, and sustained dendritic cell presentation
of the peptide leads to the extensive expansion of the CD8 T
cell with the interferon gamma secretion, leading to the macrophage
activation and the cytokine storm, and finally, the systemic symptoms
like fever, cytopenia, or hepatosplenomegaly, and
hemophagocytosis. This is the pathophysiology of the primary
HHH. However, the pathophysiology of the secondary
HHH is not clear, although they share the
common name and although the secondary HHH
diagnosed criteria is mostly derived from the primary HHH.
So our key question was, what is the immunopathology
underlying the secondary HHH, especially with the lymphoma-associated
cases?
Therefore, we generated a lymphoma cohort, especially
the diffuse large B-cell lymphoma patients, which is the most common aggressive
lymphoma. And we acquired samples from the 14
patients with the secondary HHH
at lymphoma diagnosis and compared their immune profile with the
lymphoma patients without HHH. And we also included
patients with the primary HHH to compare their
biologic features, which is the well
designated. And we acquired peripheral
blood and the bone marrow mononuclear cells
for single-cell RNA sequencing, and we also acquired plasma from their
samples for proteomics by Olink.
And interestingly, we could annotate more than
110,000 peripheral blood and bone marrow mononuclear
cells. And among these cell types, we could observe the
robust expansion of this monocyte subset in secondary HHH
patients compared with the non-HHH or primary HHH patients.
And especially the total monocyte and also the CD14 positive
monocytes were expanded in the bone marrow and peripheral blood of
secondary HHH patients compared with non-HHH or primary
HHH. So we looked deeper into the monocyte subsets,
and we could observe that the CD14 positive monocytes of this patient had
high MS1 score, which is the monocyte stage one
score.
And MS1 monocytes were recently described as the
dysfunctional myeloid cells, which was described as they enriched
in sepsis or severe COVID-19, characterized by the impaired
antigen presentation function and blunted TRL response with
IS6 and IR10 stat3-driven expansion
from the hematopoietic stem cells.
And this subset was associated with the poor outcome, especially in
the sepsis and the severe COVID-19 patients.
And we could observe the high MS1 score of the secondary HHH patient
CD14 positive monocytes, although the non-HHH and primary
HHH had less prominent MS1 score in the CD14 positive
monocytes.
We could clearly see the expansion of the MS1 score in the secondary
HHH. In addition, the representative genes such as
PRAC8, RN, IL1 receptor 2, and
alarmins such as S100 were enriched in the secondary HHH
patient monocytes. However, importantly, the MH class 2
molecules were downregulated in the CD14 positive monocyte of the
secondary HHH patients, suggesting their impaired antigen
presentation function.
We then looked upstream of these monocytes, whether this is
peripheral inflammation or whether bone marrow granulocyte
myeloid progenitors were altered.
So we looked into the hematopoietic stem cell progenitors,
and we identified the hematopoietic stem cells.
And when we analyzed the module score of these hematopoietic stem cells from the
patients, we could observe that the secondary HHH patient had
increased myeloid module score compared with the non-HHH or primary
HHH patient with less stemness, with
differentiation characteristics toward myeloid lineage.
And when we look into the GMP lineage, we can see that the GMP is
expanded in the secondary HHH patient compared with non-HHH or
primary HHH. And MS1 score was already
enriched in the GMP of the secondary HHH patients,
suggesting that the secondary HHH is not just a peripheral inflammation,
but MS1 score is already assigned in the GMP stage.
And when we analyzed the RNA velocity analysis, we could observe
that the GMP are enriched in the secondary HHH patient compared
with non-HHH. And we could see that the transition
probability, when compared with the secondary HHH to non-HHH,
we could see that the hematopoietic stem cell origin tended to
destinate to the GMP lineage, suggesting their myeloid
toward differentiation. And this suggested emergency
myelopoiesis of the secondary HHH
patients.And we then followed the
trajectory of these
MS1 monocytes by pseudotime analysis, and we could
see there are two distinct lineages of these
monocyte-myeloid. We can see that lineage one and that lineage two is
quite descriptive. And you can see that the secondary HLH
patient had distinctly lineage two monocyte toward a
bifurcation while the non-HLH or primary HLH did
not show the clear lineage differentiation toward lineage two.
And so, the secondary HLH patients had a skewed
lineage two differentiation compared with the non-HLH or
primary HLH.
And lineage two monocyte expressed high levels of the C1QR for our
CD163 with VC4 suggesting their transcription
signature.
And lineage two monocyte, when compared with the lineage one monocyte, had high
monocyte-macrophage signature, suggesting that they might be implicated in
the hemophagocytosis compared with the monocyte DC signature.
And this lineage two monocyte is indicated in red here, and the
secondary HLH patient lineage two monocyte had high expression
of the IL6, IL10, and CXCL2,
CXCL3 like inflammatory cytokines.
And this secondary HLH patient lineage two monocyte showed a high
expression of this test recently.
And so we therefore analyzed the BioCarta by potent
monocytes, and consistently this secondary HLH patient
monocyte had the enrichment at the IL6 and IL10
pathway. And we then predicted
ligands of this by niche net analysis from lineage one, two
monocytes to bipotent monocytes, and we could observe the
top four predicted ligands were IL10 and IL6 and IL1 and
TNF beta, suggesting that the lineage two monocyte may
reinforce MS1 program via IL6 and IL10.
And we also analyzed the proteomics by Olink
assay, and we could confirm the increased expression of the
IL6 and IL10 in plasma of secondary HLH
patients, both in the bone marrow and the peripheral blood.
And importantly, the bone marrow plasma levels of the IL6 and IL10
was significantly correlated with the MS1 score of monocytes
of the secondary HLH patients, which was not observed in the
non-HLH patients.
And we also looked at beyond the monocyte, and when we looked into the
conventional DCs, their frequency was decreased.
So in my first slide, I showed you that the primary HLH
is associated with the continuous DC
expansion, but the secondary HLH pathogenesis was quite
different because their frequency was decreased.
And we also observed that their MH2 class molecules were
downregulated in the CDC of the secondary HLH
patients with difference in signature.
However, the class one molecule was upregulated while the class two
was downregulated, suggesting the MH1 to imbalance of the
conventional DCs of the secondary HLH patients.
And finally, we looked into the CD8 positive T cells, and in
secondary HLH patients, the TM2 cluster was observed
while non-HLH patient and primary HLH patient did not
demonstrate significant enrichment of this TM cluster.
And this TM cluster showed high levels of granzyme B with the
stress response and OXPHOS and glycolysis enrichment
genes. And when we looked at the exhaustion features of
these subsets, TM features showed a high
exhaustion module score. However, they expressed as high levels
of CTLA4, PD1, LAG3, and TIM3,
but their expression was quite low of talks, and
we're suggesting they are exhausted, but they're not classically exhausted.
But they are activated, maybe dysfunctionally activated.
So conclude, we show that the lymphoma-associated
secondary HLH was marked by the emergency myopoiesis that we
detected GMP differentiation toward MS1 like
dysfunctional monocytes. And we show that the lineage two monocytes
are expanded, and they may further reinforce the
IL6 and TNF test three axis to maintain the MS1
pathologic program. And this was accompanied by the reduced CDC
abundance and impaired MH2 class presentation, which
may heighten the inflammatory signaling.
And these findings support the monocyte-centered framework of secondary
HLH pathophysiology and potential therapeutic targeting
of these monocytes, especially the lineage two monocyte, might
help a patient suffering from this disease.
So I was able to present this work thanks to our lab members,
especially Dr. Chonghun Qua and Jun Yong.
And the primary HLH samples was acquired from the Samsung Medical Center.
And thank you for your attention, and I'll be happy to answer any
question.
Thank you. Excellent talk. Any questions?
I have a question. First of all, this is a lot of work.
Anyone who has taken care of HLH patients, they know
it's fatal. There is very limited time from
diagnosis to treatment and to collect samples at
this level. It's a lot of work.
I have two questions. I'll start with the first one.
Were these samples taken before or
after
the diagnosis and/or after the treatment?
Yeah. Thank you for the important question. Yes.
These samples were acquired at diagnosis of
HLH. So these samples were treatment naive,
not straight exposed samples.
Thank you.
I had a question. These
progenitor level MS1 imprinting that you
observed, were these also observed in
primary HLH patients-
Oh, yeah
... who carried PRF1 or UNCP13D
mutations, or was it
exclusive to secondary HLH cases?
Yes. Thank you for the important comment.
And we include the patient with UNC13D, four patients, and
two patients we perform one mutation in the pediatric patients,
less than one year. And we could also observe some
level of MS1 score in this CD14 monocytes of these pediatric
patients. However, not as much as the secondary HLH patients.
And we are sure that by
quantitative analysis suggesting that the MS1 score was
significantly higher in the secondary HLH patients compared with the primary
HLH patients.
Thank you.
I had a question about your DC data.
You show CDC.
There's CDC1s and CDC2s. I was just curious about the CD16
expression.
Were you able to quantify,
maybe I missed it, the
CD16 expression on those CDCs, if they're CDC1 or CDC2?
Yes. Thank you for the important comment.
We actually quantified CD16 expression on monocyte of
our samples, but due to the time limit, I didn't bring that data.
But the CD16 expression was quite high in the
MS2 monocytes. But we couldn't observe
as much
expression of the CD16 in
both CDC1 and CDC2 because their frequency was quite low,
less than 1%.
Okay.
Do we have any other questions from the floor?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I wanted to say thank you to all presenters for delivering such
elegant and impactful science this afternoon.
This mini-symposium on modifiers of inflammation and the
tumor microenvironment has illustrated how
diverse cellular and molecular factors,
including stromal niches,
engineered microbes, reprogrammed macrophages,
vaccine-boosted bystander T cells,
cytokine-armed T cells, and emergency
myelopoiesis converge to reshape inflammation,
dictate immune architecture, and ultimately determine
whether tumors evade or succumb to therapy.
Across melanoma, bladder cancer, breast cancer,
pancreatic cancer, and lymphoma, we heard recurring
and complementary themes. First,
spatial organization matters profoundly.
I learned from Jackson that conserved
anti-inflammatory hubs rich in
SPP1 macrophages and post-N
fibroblasts actively drive neural
crest-like dedifferentiation and cytokine
resistance while sequestering exhausted singleton
T cell clonotypes.
Roxandra complemented this by demonstrating
that deletion of host-derived
GPNMB
reprograms TAMS towards an
interferon-driven, pro-inflammatory state
while unleashing cytotoxic T cell infiltration and
activation.
Second, precise immunomodulatory engineering can
break suppressive circuits and recruit
endogenous immunity.
Matthew's synthetic E. coli nisle expressing
CXCL13
hijacks germinal center biology to
amplify tumor-specific antibody responses
and synergize with PD-1 blockade in bladder cancer.
Liam's unexpected bystander CAR T
activation via simple FITC-targeted
vaccine triggered rapid interferon gamma-dependent
cytokine chemokine storms that remodeled
distant tumor microenvironments,
driving more than 70%
regression, even in antigen mismatched settings.
Audrey extended this theme
by showing that interleukin 18 secreting CAR T
cells achieves superior control of
antigen heterogeneous tumors,
not through stronger neoantigen-specific
CD8 priming, but via potent type
II interferon program that expands and
activates myeloid effectors.
The last one is cancer-driven myelopoiesis
can be hijacked to sustain
hyperinflammation and immunosuppression
simultaneously. Hyunsoo's single-cell atlas
of lymphoma-associated secondary
HLH
revealed tumor-induced emergency myelopoiesis
that imprints an MS1-like immunosuppressive program
at the hematopoietic stem cell and GMP stage.
Taken together, these abstracts converge on
unifying principle, which is inflammation in
the tumor microenvironment is highly context
dependent and therapeutically malleable.
Looking forward, a critical area for
us to work on would be to understand
that these tumor-promoting
inflammatory cells
driving cancer cell dedifferentiation and T cell
exhaustion, but how
the same circuits could be disrupted or
redirected via synthetic biology,
bystander vaccines, or interleukin
18-armed CAR T cells
in order to restore
effective anti-tumor immunity.
I want to thank our co-chair, Dr. Zarif, for his
leadership in opening this session,
all presenters for their clarity and generosity with data,
and the AACR for curating this timely program.
Most importantly, thank you to the audience.
Your insights have already enriched today's
dialogue. We look forward to continuing these
discussions beyond
as we translate these mechanistic insights
into the next generation of inflammation-modifying
therapies. Thank you.
Roxandra.
Miss Tonia.
Oh, thank you